ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى التفاصيل الحفاوه
التي استقبل بها الرئيس الامريكي في بعض
نظيره الفرنسي ماكرون ورائها خلاف كبير
اقره الزعمان خلال لقائهما بالبيت الابيض
الخلافات تعود لعده اسباب من بينهم
الاعانات الجديده المقدمه بموجب القانون
الامريكي لخفضه التضخم وكن بيضا وقع في
اغسطس الماضي على قانون يقدم دعما بقبتي
430 مليار دولارا للمنتجات الامريكيه تصنع
ويهدف الى معالجه ازمه المناخ وتقليسا
بعثه الغازات المحليه وقد نقش مكرونه مع
بيض ان المخاوي في الفرنسيه والاوروبيه
ازاء الاعانات المقدمات بموجب هذا القانون
الامريكي فيما قال احد المشاركين في
اجتماعا عقده مكروه مع مشرعنا امريكانا
قال ان مكروه وصف قانون خفض التضخم بانه
عدوانيه للغايات الشركات الاوروبيه التحذي
اوروبيه 2 عامه والفرنسيه تحديدا ليست
جدده اذا اتهم الجانبان امريكا في وقت
السابق بالتربح من الحرب الاوكرانيه خاصه
فيما يتعلق بالطاقه والغاز كل هذه
الاتهامات والخلافات دافعت ماكرون الى
ارسال تحذيرا للامريكينا بانه او بان
افعلهم قد تؤدي لتقسيم الغرب في اشاره
الموقف الموحد الحالي تجاه روسيا والحرب
الاوكرانيه
والفضاء وقد تحدثت على اعاده التوافق
والتنسيق المشترك واعتقدوا ان هذا مهم جدا
ليكون لدينا تنسيق كبير بيننا لاننا نريد
ان نصلح العواقب المباشره والغير مباشره
للحرب على اقتصاداتنا وعلى شعوبنا وفي نفس
الوقت نريد التحضير للاشياء القادمه
[موسيقى]
اناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفينا منه احمد
الحنطي البحث في شان الامريكي اهلا بك ومن
باريس الباحث السياسيه دكتور خلدون
النبواني اهلا بك دكتور واسمحلي ان ابدا
معك
بتصريحات رئيس الفرنسي ماكرون الرئيس
ماكرون كان واضح في تصريحاته تحدث عن ان
هذه الاجراءات الامريكيه الاخيره
وخاصه بذكر مشروع القانون الذي يقول بايضا
بانه يحض من التضخم
ويساعد شركات همم محليه همم امريكيه يقول
مكروم بان هذا سيؤدي الى تفتت اوروبا
وسيضر بمصالح الاوروبيين هل نحن امام ازمه
دكتور ومن يتحمل مسؤولياتها
مساء الخير ريم ورديتك الكريم وب مشاهدي
قناه العربيه هناك ازمه ازمه فعليه حقيقيه
يمكن احتوائها وهذا ما دفع ماكرون الى
الذهاب الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
طبعا لا يمكن اعاده النظر بقانون تخفيض
يعني التضخم همم ولكن يمكن استثناء همم
الحاله الاوروبيه ماذا يعني ذلك القانون
هناك مساعدات كبيره ومعونات كبيره مقدمه
للشركات الصديقه للبيئه ربما بين قوسين
صديقا للبيئه وبخصص السيارات الكهربائيه
والبطاريات همم
يعني ذات الاثر البيئي القليل وبالتالي
همم كل ذلك قد يدفع الشركات المقيمه
باوروبا بالذهاب الى امريكا
المساعدات مما يؤدي لان القانون الامريكي
لحد تلك المساعده بالشركات الموجوده على
الاراضي الامريكيه وبالتالي كل ذلك يمكن
ان يسبب يعني ان يمثل بشكل او باخر حاله
من الحرب الاقتصاديه التي بدات منذ عهد
ترامب ورغم ان الاجواء 13 مع بيض الا ان
الحرب الاقتصاديه حقيقه لم تتوقف بشكل
عالمي همم
اقتصاديه هناك ازمه اقتصاديه خانقه تعيشها
اوروبا لما تقول بان هذه الشركات ربما
ستتجه الى امريكا لانه هناك مساعدات
يقولوا لبعض كبيره لشركات همم
محليه همم ولكن هذا سيضعف كذلك الاقتصاد
الاوروبي ما رايك استاذ احمد همم هل هناك
همم دقه في كلام ماكرون بان هذه الاجراءات
ستضعف الاقتصاد الاوروبي ستدخل الاقتصاد
في ازمه المضاعفه ويمكن ان تحذف انقساما
اوروبيه
لا اعرف عن مدى تاثير هذه الاجراءات على
الاقتصاد الاوروبي تحديدا يعني لست خبير
في الاقتصاد الاوروبي ولكن الاوروبيين
ارتكبوا خطا كبير عندما ظنوا ان هذا
القانون لن يمر هذا القانون يعني طرح من
بدايه 2021 كان بنت رئيسي على جنطه
بايدينا التشريعيه يعني يمر بمشاكل كثير
واعيد تغليفه اكثر من مره واعيد تسميته
وادخل في تعديلات كبيره الين مؤخرا يبدون
الاوروبيين كانوا يتوقعون ان هذا القانون
لن يمر بسبب الخلاف الديمقراطي الديمقراطي
حول تفاصيله لكنه مروره يعني هم يلعبوا في
الوقت بدل الضايع خلاص القانون مر وانتهى
والمشكله الكبيره اليوم يعانونها انه همم
حزمه الدعم يعني التسهيلات المقدمه
للشركات العامله في مجال السيارات
الكهربائيه ليست مكسوره على امريكا هي
تشمل امريكا الشماليه بمعنى ان تشمل كندا
والمكسيك في الاوروبيين غاضبون من ذلك
يقولون يعني لماذا لماذا تمنح كندا
والمكسيك هذا الامتياز ولا تملحه دول
اوروبا نحن فن هناك كثير من شركات صناعه
السيارات الاوروبيه يعني لديها مصانع
تجميع سواء في امريكا او في المكسيك فهم
يرغون ان هذا القانون يعني سيدفع هذه
الشركات لتوسع اكبر في هذه المناطق بدل
التوسع في اوروبا ولكن استاذ احمد حضرتك
تعرف بان الموضوع لا يقتصر فقط على هذا
القانون الموضوع موضوع الازمه الدبلوماسيه
حتى اسمها البعض بين الطرف الامريكي وطرف
الاوروبي وفرنسا بتحديد بدات قبل ذلك بدات
خلال الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه همم كانت
هناك تهامات لبعض بانه يبيع الغاز
الامريكي اربعه اضعاف ما يبيعه لداخل
الامريكي همم وهناك حتى ازمه ما قبل ذلك
وكان ضيفنا الاستاذ خلدون كان سيتحدث عن
هذا الموضوع عن تحالفوس التي اعتبرت فرنسا
بانه تم اقصاءها من هذا التحالف البريطاني
الاسترالي الامريكي اللي شمله بايع غواصات
ولشما والذي شمل كذلك تمضع استراتيجي في
محيطي الهادي والهندي وبالتالي فرنسا ترى
استاذ احمد بان هناك وكان شيئا من الخداع
الامريكي عبر المراحل هل هذا دقيق
الاشكاليه في موضوع الغاز ان الغاز يختلف
عن النفط يعني النفط له اسواق عالميه تحدد
سعره بشكل متقارب يعني في مختلف مناطق
العالم الغاز لا ينطبق عليه هذا الشيء
لذلك يوجد اختلافات كبيره في اسعار الغاز
بين منطقه واخرى والاوربيين غاضبون من كون
الغاز الامريكي رخيص جدا داخل امريكا يعني
مقارنه بالاسعار في مناطق اخرى في العالم
لماذا تبيع علينا باسعار عاليه بينما
تبيعه داخل امريكا باسعار رخيصه همم قد
يكون لديهم وجهه نظر بحكم اننا نتحدث عن
نتائج حرب مشتركه يعني تاخذها اوروبا
وامريكا معا في اوكرانيا لكن موضوع موضوع
عن الغواصات هذا الموضوع همم
رغم ان فرنسا كانت يعني ضحيه لان همم هذه
خطها استراتيجيه طويله لمواجهه الصين حتى
حتى في موضوع البطاريات السيارات يعني
موضوع السيارات الكهربائيه في الواقع
امريكا انوي مواجهه الصين يعني مواجهه
اقتصاديه في اقتصاديه المستقبل طبعا كانت
هذا يعني هناك جالي الرئيسيين لهذه
المواجهه اللي هي الذكاء الاصطناعي
والطاقه نظيفه في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعيه
لشاهدنا قانون شيبس اللي يعني منع الصين
من الوصول الى التقنيات الحديثه في هذا
المجال الاوروبيه لا يرى المشكله في هذا
الامر لانهم لا يستطيعون منافسه لامريكا
الى الصين في هذا المجال ايضا في موضوع
الطاقه النظيفه عندما نتكلم مثلا احنا
الواحد طاقه الشمسيه وما خلافه اصيل لديها
تمييز كبيره امريكا تحاول ان تسحب ببساطه
من تحتها ولكنهم يرون انفسهم الضحيه في
تحديدا في موضوع السيارات لانه الاوروبيه
متقدمين جدا في موضوع السيارات الاوروبيه
معروفه بجودتها وهم لا يريدون ان يتم
اخراجهم من هذا السوق المستقبلي ولكني ارى
ان الفرصه فاتت ربما يتمكن من الحصول على
تنازلات امريكيه في مجالات اخرى في مقابل
هذا لكن هذا القانون لن يتغير ولن يحدث
فيه اي شيء
الدكتور خلدون هل ترى فعلا كما يرى ضيفي
بان هناك متغيرات وهناك حق امريكا كذلك في
ان يعد الى سيادته بما يتناسب مع مصالحه
ام انك ترى بالعكس كما يرى الاوروبيون ان
هذه المتغيرات جعلت من امريكا واوروبا في
نفس همم الاطار الذي يحارب روسيا والذي كل
مره يصدر عقوبات الذي يتحمل كذلك تدعيات
هذه الحرب وعلى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان ترتب كذلك حساباتها بما
يتجاوب مع المصالح الاوروبيه
اطار ما صدر عن مكروم في هذه الزياره حول
همم نساء بها على مثل هذا السؤال او سؤال
شبيه هو قال بان من حق الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه طبعا ان تفكر في اقتصادها في
اعانه الشركات الموجوده على اراضيها بتحدي
الصين ولكن الخوف كله من ان هذا يعني على
حساب الحلفاء بمعنى ان ما هكذا يتعامل
الخلفاء الحلفاء حينما انتقد الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يجب ان تراعي همم
حلفاءها لا تبيع سعر الغاز والنفط الغاز
بشكل تحديد باربع اضعاف احيانا بخمس اضعاف
السعر الموجوده وبالتالي همم مكرون
واوروبا من ورائه يطمحون بان يكون هناك
تعامل استثنائي لاوروبا الحديثه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
فرنسا فرنسا
كمتابع ومراقب لكل هذا هل ترى ان هناك
استغلال لاوروبا كما يقول مكروم
طبعا طبعا هناك استغلال واستغلال كبير اا
اوروبا هي التي دفعت ثمن الحرب الاوكرانيه
اوروبا هي التي تجد نفسها في حرب ايضا مع
حلفتها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بمعنى
ان امريكا استفادت كثيرا من اسعار الغاز
وارتفاعها اسعار الطاقه عموما النفط
والغاز بينما اوروبا هي التي تدفع امريكا
ونفطها الى اوروبا وجعلت منها سوقا
وبالتالي هناك شيء من التبعيه الخاضعه
هناك شيء من الاعتماد الاقتصادي لاوروبا
على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي لا
تستطيع في هذه الظروف الاقصى الظروف عدم
وجود واحده اوروبيه وجيش اوروبي واحد كما
يطالب مايكرون للاستقلال قليل عن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كل ذلك يجعل اوروبا
خاضعه وتابعه اقتصاديا على الاقل للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وحتى امنيه انه بذلك
تحاول اوروبا همم اول انا تجد شيئا من
الاستقلاليه عن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه رغم ان هذه الامور
وبعيده وايضا بنفس الوقت تطالب الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بالتعامل معها كحليف
همم يخضع لاستثناءات وليس كما اا تفرضه
اليه السوق او كما تجيب امريكا اوروبا كل
مره هذا هو سعر السوق ماذا تريدوننا ان
نفعله بالتالي هم يطمحون بتعامل مميز همم
لاوروبا مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اقتصاديا على الاقل استاذ احمد هل تعتقد
بان واشنطن تتعمد اضعاف اوروبا استغلال
اوروبا همم تفتيت اوروبا هناك كذلك ما خوف
من قسمات هذا قد يعيش ولا الاتحاد
الاوروبي على خلفيات تدعيه الحرب وعلى
خلفيه ازمه الطاقه والان على خلفيه
تداعيات ما يمكن ان يكون من وراء قانون
همم خفض التضخم هذا
لا اعتقد ان الغرض اضعاف اوروبا لانه
امريكا تحتاج الى اوروبا في مواجهتها مع
الصين المشكله انه الموانع الامريكيه غير
جاهزه لتصدير الغاز بكميات كبيره
لتجهيزها يعني لتمكينها من فعل ذلك تحتاج
الى استثمارات ضخمه الحكومه التي تستثمر
اموال في تجهيز موانئ تصدر الغاز بينما
توجه اصلا الى حوار يعني بدائل لهذا يعني
الوقود الاحفوري
فالشركات لكي تقدم هذه الاستثمارات يجب ان
يكون السعر مغري اذا لم يكن السعر مغري
فلن لن تبنى هذه المحطات داخل الموانئ
الموجوده لتصدير الغاز بكميه اكبر فهذه
العمليه موازنه يعني قد تقدم امريكا بعد
التنازلات المؤقته لاوروبا في مجال لتخفيف
ازمه الشتاء القادم ولكنه لن يكون لن تكون
تنازلت كبيره لان المشكله انهم ينظرون الى
اقتصاد النفط والغاز انه اقتصاد الماضي
وليس اقتصاد
معكرونه تحدث عن استغلال هو يرى بان هذه
التنازلات الامريكيه المحدوده التي قد تضر
بالمصالح الاوروبيه هي نوع من انواع
الاستغلال
نعم ماكرون يرى ذلك قد يكون حقا ولكن ايضا
امريكا تنظر انها هي تدافع عن اوروبا
فعليا في اوكرانيا
ليست هذه ليست حرب امريكا لوحدها هي في
الواقع حرب اوروبا بالدرجه الاولى وشاهدنا
ذلك يعني في بدايه الحرب بين انه كانت راس
الحرب بريطانيا وليست امريكا في البدايه
فامريكا لا تريد ان تدافع عن اوروبا على
حسابها بل تريد اوروبا ان تتحمل جزء كبير
من التكلفه عن طريق شراء الغاز الامريكي
باسعار مرتفعه هو لا نعلم ان كانت
بريطانيا راس الحرب ولكن نتذكر كذلك لانه
تصريحات البريطانيه كانت الامريكيه عفوا
كانت متشنجه في البدايه وكانت هي التي
روشت لفكره بدايه غزو روسي على اوكرانيا
همم فالبعض كذلك استاذ احمد يقول بانه
امريكا هي التي جرت وراءها اوروبا ما رايك
همم
هل همم امريكا هي التي تحارب روسيا من اجل
اوروبا او العكس صحيح وقد تضطر اوروبا
لدفع الثمن
يعني لا شك ان ان ال ال الاستراتيجيه او
الرؤيه الامريكيه لهذه الحرب تختلف عن
الرؤيه الاوروبيه ليست ان الحرب على اراضي
اوروبيه وهي الحرب الاولى التي يعني
تشهدها اوروبا او منذ نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ولكن هناك استراتيجيه
اقتصاديه واستراتيجيه همم جيو استراتيجيه
على الاقل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تدفع باوروبا همم فيها في قطن هذه الحرب
بشكل همم بشكل عنيف بمعنى اخر هناك رغبه
باستنزاف روسيا قويه وعذاء كبير لروسيا من
قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تجد
اوروبا على هذا الموقف صائب وبالتالي هي
تحاول ان تلعب دور الوسيط على الاقل هي
تلعب دور اقل عنفا واقل احد في مواجهه
روسيا من هنا كلام مكرون وسورس بشكل متكرر
حول ضروره ترك الباب مفتوحا للتفاوض مع
روسيا في حين ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه جاهزه الاستنفاد كل الاوكرانيين
في هذه الحرب استنفاق حتى
العتاب والاموال الاوروبيه في هذه الحرب
لا شك ان اوروبا تدفع اقل من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لكن هذا القليل
الاوروبي يضعف اقتصاد ضعيف همم قياسا
بالقياب الاقتصاد الامريكي وبالتالي
اوروبا تستنظف في هذا الموضوع ملف اخر
ايضا يثير همم المشاكل ما بين اوروبا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهو ايضا ملف
اقتصادي العلاقه مع الصين في حين تذهب همم
امريكا في حاله صراع مفتوح مع الصين تجد
اوروبا ان لا مصلحه لها في هذا الصراع هي
سوق كبيره للصين لديها معاملات اقتصاديه
مهمه في هذا الصدد وهي يعني ذهبت في هذا
السياسه على الطريقه الامريكيه فهي ستخسر
كثيرا وكل ذلك اذا يجعل هناك تمايز في
النظره همم للعديد من الملفات بين اوروبا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
حدود خلافات اعمق في الاتحاد الاوروبي كيف
سيكون تاثير ذلك على العلاقه مع واشنطن
وعلى الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه ك وهل
ستحمل واشنطن يا استاذ احمد كل هذه
التداعيات ربما يكون موضوع حلقه اخرى او
شكرا لكم جزيل الشكر من هيوستن احمد
الحمصي الباحث في شان الامريكي ومن باريس
الباحث السياسي دكتور خلدون النبواني شكرا
لكم